you both look fantastic thank you for
being here we don't often do this we
don't often do the podcast with an
audience but I like it I performed in
front of audiences for almost 30 years
loved it I feel I get a lot of energy
from it sometimes I'm giving cocaine
after the show I hope from the audience
oh yeah
who's the coke mule today
trust me always in the back
um he's a lovely guy anyway uh I'm
really happy I'm really happy that we
have a crowd here and Sona tell us uh
how are you how's your life going
everything's good
okay well that's all the time we have
yay no I have there's really nothing I
wish there was I wish there was some
excitement I mean I've like keep my
friends keep telling me when they go out
and I don't go out like I use oh but you
you went out during in your use and for
maybe 10 years we were working together
you tore it up I did you went out every
night and killed it yeah and then uh
slept mostly at work the next day yes I
did speaking of a rum and then uh so you
had your fun you had your guitar I did
it's just weird that like now I don't I
don't do that anymore well I think Matt
Gourley does enough partying for all of
us yeah right no
you know last time we did the uh podcast
in front of this in this room in front
of an audience like this there was a
woman who only came here to see you was
it the one that I wasn't here or was you
were not here yeah yeah and you weren't
here and she only came here to see you
and I said of course you probably you
know I said no big deal but Matt
gorley's not going to be here today
thinking that it would you know not even
be a speed bump in the road
this woman was heartbroken maybe she was
here to kill me though I don't know she
did have a weapon yeah did she yell out
Pasadena oh yeah I think that's her
right I think it was here for that okay
no no you were not you were not here she
was really disappointed I hone in on a
disappointed audience member when
someone's less than pleased with me this
comes from childhood if someone slightly
less than pleased from me my skin burns
and so I was quite aware that something
was off with the crowd and I found it I
talked to this woman I don't know if she
ever and then it turns out she knows
where you live not address wise she knew
what street you were on you know really
yeah I told her
I told her exactly and I said there's
there it says there's an alarm system
but it's not real they just got the sign
this is my new mistress yes oh yes oh
she's great that's how you met your
mistress yes she literally came in
through the garage uh well I hope uh you
guys are you know hope you're doing well
yeah as I said you're you were kind of
wearing cogs in this machine same jacket
we didn't even plan this these are chord
Bros yeah corn Bros you guys in corduroy
yeah a party yep nothing says an
exciting night of fun
like two middle-aged white guys in
corduroy think of the noise make if we
hugged
strangest pickup line I've ever heard
that's what my mister said the minute
she peeked out the door
I often say that think of the noise we'd
make if we hug
I don't even remember how I used to try
and start and chat with ladies back in
the day did you have a line I didn't
have it well I used to say I didn't know
Angels flew so low no no you wouldn't do
that never did that the audience was
horrified yeah no I never ever ever did
anything like that I usually say this
skin will clear up
[Laughter]
10 years in 10 years it'll be a drug and
then you'll love me that wasn't even
your voice you were just doing that
voice that was my voice then I've had
several operations since then no I I
didn't have good game I didn't really
have good game you know did you use any
kind of first line with your wife Liza
when you met her was there any like
first quip or first uh I met Eliza when
I was shooting a remote in New York city
so it's all on I mean you would know
better than I would because it was on
camera right I talked to her I met an
advertising agency and I was supposed to
shoot a remote there and the cameras are
rolling and I just start talking to this
woman and very quickly I'm not even
trying to be funny I'm not Conan in a
remote yeah I'm Conan O'Brien saying in
love
not yet
um oh no I'm kidding uh I'm Conan
O'Brien just saying things like no no
that's really cool and so your father oh
okay I get it and she's then saying
asking me questions I'm like no no I
mean I studied English but then I also
studied history and my producer was
listening with you know a headset on I
was like what is what is wrong with him
what's going on and uh so it's now out
there our kids have watched us meet
that's amazing it's in 2000 we met in
2000 yeah and so they've watched us meet
and I don't want to watch it because I
remember it and I know this sounds
schmaltzy but I know what I know that
that moment was special to me and I
don't want to see it you know uh in a
digital format does that make sense yeah
I think so yeah yeah that's nice does it
make sense to you guys yeah I think you
think it's kind of sweet
okay what the hell is wrong with you
people
such why can't you just
part isn't it sweets I
bullied them into it
it's so sweet